[Music]
welcome to GameSpot's coverage of e3
2018 I'm Callie and I'm here with Thomas
mauler CEO and gaming director over at
Moon Studios and we're gonna be talking
about Ori and the will of the wisp
yes so you guys announced last year and
you should have some gameplay at e3 can
you talk a little bit about talk us
through the kind of what we saw during
the press conferences so we announced
the game last year we announced with
just issuing a couple of environments a
little bit of art and so on and
basically just saying here making
another aura game right so this year we
knew well gamers would really just want
to say hey you know shut up short
gameplay so we did just that I mean we
came with a trailer that was really
really focused on gameplay this time
around and then we also at the show
floor we're showing a playable build we
were showing basically three main big
three main big things so there's a whole
new combat system so as you see when or
is jumping around right now and so on
there's spells now there's different
weapons that aura can wield and we try
to really take it further than any
Metroidvania has ever done it before so
every single weapon has its own
animation style and so on the play
styles are completely different between
those weapons and yeah we just really
wanted to elevate the combat this time
around to the same level that we did
platforming for the first game okay so
that's kind of your focus is the first
game is platforming and this one's more
this time it's both right like we wanted
to elevate the platforming even more and
a lot of times in development but we
when we started but we loved the wisps
it was it was a lot about hey what cool
new moves will already be able to do
this time right but then also like I'm
I'm crazy about reading all the message
boards and like all the press stuff like
what what critics have been saying and a
lot of them did want to have more
variety in combat so we just basically
said hey we want to have that on that
level as well and really go crazy at
this time so did the feedback on the
first or a really influential of the
West fun it absolutely did I'm on all
these forums and so on I read what
defense write what offense write I read
every single review that's out there and
yeah I just like to assets really about
art and the craft right and and and we
really want to make this perfect
package where we just perfect that thing
because I think there's a lot of aura
fans out there that know that and we
want them to know hey when we ship
something but it's a little masterpiece
right that it's really something that
even ten years from now you can still
enjoy playing it right that it's this
perfectly crafted package so I know you
guys can't really talk about story too
much now but is there a story reason for
certain weapons and abilities this time
around
yeah we're not giving that away you know
what that's fair and won't want to be
spoiled I know you know story is
something really important in Orion
that's something that that really
resonated with a lot of people and I'm
sure you've read but knowing that you
read so much of the feedback gosh thank
you hard reading feedback as a creator
knowing what you intended to make and
seeing how people receive it know we
really enjoy it I mean generally I'm
kind of like a little bit of a
perfectionist and we had a lot of people
that know that a perfectionist so we
read like it's nice to see all the
positive comments and so on right and we
really like watching people in YouTube
crying while they're playing sorry but
I'm really always looking for you know
is there any criticism and how can we do
even better right how can we make it how
can we craft something that is that
takes it even further or some people
yeah I mean there were a lot of people
that enjoy it oriental pine forest and
but there are some people that you know
that that liked it but then certain
aspects of it they wish to have more
often and so at this time we really try
to get everybody right so we're hoping
that even people who didn't who we
didn't quite get with oriental pine
forest who preferred other Metroidvania
that we this time really have something
for them what besides you know having
more you know strict Metroidvania
aspects was one of the criticisms that
you guys tried to address this time
around I think that combis was the
combat was to pick one and the other
thing that people brought up was that
the game was fairly difficult right I
was going to say the blame for is is a
pretty difficult game yeah so the thing
is though we didn't want to take away
the challenge we we like a good
challenge I mean and games have a kind
of like a renaissance with that now
right like with Dark Souls and these
kind of things that no challenging games
can be a lot of fun right
but did this time like we really looked
at well what is frustrating about Orie
and there were a couple of things that
were frustrating for example we had the
escape sequences nori and the blind
forest that we're pretty difficult they
were kind of like our versions of bosses
because the game was very much focused
on platforming so at the end of every
single Benjen and so you had to escape
the dungeon right and really perform all
the moves that that we taught you
during this dungeon right and but there
were a couple of things like for example
in before any of these escape sequences
we saved your game so basically we told
you hey you really have to finish that
sequence right now in order to continue
playing the game and this time we kind
of like solved that we made sure that
hey people can go out go back to the
overworld explore a little bit more - a
couple of more quests right upgrade
their abilities their skills and so on
and then come back when they're ready so
we didn't want to do baby mode right and
just simplify things we wanted to still
make the game but really pack a punch
but give the player the ability to
really you know learn and and you know
and play the sequence the difficult
sequence when they're ready to do so
okay so not a difficulty slider or
difficulty options but just a little bit
more forewarning when you're about to go
into something I'll check bring
difficulty options into the definitive
edition of blind 4 right like we haven't
decided yet um we're currently designing
the game in a way where we hope it's a
it's that it that it fits for everybody
because you can sort of regulate the
difficulty for yourself by choosing
which spirit rights you use and so on so
we we completely redesigned the ability
tree that was in orient the pine forest
so this time for example if you have
trouble with platforming excuse me that
we have spirit charts that you can equip
that then make your platforming a little
bit easier right but if you have trouble
with combat that there's also shirts for
that and so on so we really want to give
these tools to the player and and help
them that way but also you know really
bring in a variety in terms of hey if
you want to play in a certain way you
should be able to do so right like
there's schemes out there like for
example when I play a Dark Souls
it doesn't really allow me to play
through the game with just a bowl right
but if I wanna play that way then as a
play I think I should have the tools
available to actually play that way and
with that spirit chart system that we
bring and that we're bringing in we're
really giving you that ability and it
goes to crazy levels all the modifiers
today in the game right now how you can
craft the combat to your particular
playstyle is super cool I'm really glad
you brought up other games like Dark
Souls because in a previous interview
that we did with you guys I'm not sure
who mentioned it but somebody mentioned
that Mario was a big inspiration for Ori
oh yeah and I was wondering if you could
expand on that a little because I find
that really interesting especially
because tonally they are completely
different games I mean I grew up playing
Mario right I grew up playing games like
Super Mario Bros and Super Mario Bros 3
and so on one of the design philosophies
actually four oriented would have the
wisps was when Microsoft first
approaches about making sequel I kind of
told them hey I only want to make the
game if you allow us to turn will of the
wisps to make will of the wisps should
be two blind forest what Super Mario
Bros 3 was the super my plus one so we
wanted to take the game the core fit
that was all really good but improve
upon it on every level right and yeah I
mean to me Nintendo games are generally
huge influence I think you see that when
we when you look at or a write that we
we definitely take inspiration from
Mario from Zelda from Metroid and yeah
but I think at this point Ori is kind of
like its own thing and it became its own
thing and there's definitely like we
definitely try to push that for it as
well we have a lot more NPCs like
characters in the game we were lucky
enough that on Orion the blind forest
people really already felt emotionally
attached to our characters and I love
that so we brought in a lot more
characters that all have their own
unique story lines right that also give
you quests and so on and they also go
through their challenges as or it goes
through his journey and I think that's
gonna be really cool for people to see I
think we have to wrap up pretty soon but
can you say even I know you can't talk
about story but can you say when we can
expect maybe to hear a little bit more
about that uh about the story yes
as time goes by we just want to make
sure that we keep it a little bit close
to chest because I know that or is a
game where a lot of people played
because of the story and because they
feel so emotionally attached to the
characters and so on and this time I
think the story the way we like the the
game basically continues or integral of
the wisp continue continues right after
orient the blind forest and this time we
really like changed the theme a little
bit to me orient the pines forest was a
lot about the law of parents have for
their children
this time it's about siblings basically
well thank you so much for that little
Tivat I'm I'm very very excited and
again Thank You Thomas Mahler from Moon
Studios thank you for giving us a little
bit of rundown on our soloists you can
find out more about Ori on games felt
right now because we have a ton of
coverage on e3 2018 so if you missed
anything go check that out right now we
have all of it and we'll see you next
time
[Music]